yo what is up everybody mad Luigi here
no man sky is out and there's a lot to
do in it so much so that you probably
missed a couple of these gameplay tips
that I'm gonna be showing you in this
video that would really make your life a
lot better Shaun Murray and his team met
hello games have made it clear they
don't want to spoil everything they
don't want to tell you how to do
everything however they still put in
that tutorial message in the bottom
right that never goes away and is always
something different that doesn't really
help most of the time but I'm going to
be better than that and I'm going to
give you five nuggets of knowledge that
you actually want number one flying
upside down or sideways have you ever
been strolling in on a planet heading up
to a trading post or any other objective
marker and you fly over it and you try
and get close and you can't see it and
the ground bumps you up use the auto
assist for flying well now if you want
to be more precise in that as you come
in hit one of the two bumpers so you can
see below you once you find a spot where
you want to be hit square the land and
it's easy-peasy number two now I bet
you're coming over to me being like math
Luigi you best better have a tip for
moving faster because I move slow as
molasses well you're in luck because I
do so before I save this tip I'm gonna
credit reddit with this I'm gonna link
where I found this on a reddit post I
did not come up with this however I'm
just giving you a video tutorial on how
to do it alright to do this you're going
to start sprinting it's not completely
necessary I think however the reddit
post says this so we're just going to go
with it starts printing press your melee
which is r1 and then as soon as you
press your melee hold the jetpack button
and you should get a super boost and fly
really fast this happens because if
you're running and or if you're moving
forward not necessarily running and you
hit the bumper to melee your melee takes
you forward it's like a quick little
dash and when you hit the jetpack it'll
boost you off of that - you'll maintain
that speed but you'll continue it in
full high this is about like at least
three times faster than normal sprinting
or walking it'll get you to your
locations that would take fifty seconds
in like five so hot tip number three
uploading this is something that's
easily looked over since it's not super
obvious as Shaun Murray said most of the
stuff won't be obvious but
upload your discoveries and try and get
all the animals so if you go to a planet
and you see a bunch of stuff you scan a
bunch of stuff with your little
multi-tool scanner scan animal scan
plans find locations you'll get a couple
thousand units for every single
discovery and you can redeem these by
the options button go somewhere and
you'll be able to upload those you can
rename them if you want you don't need
to and what's especially cool is you if
you find every species of animal on the
planet you'll get around 200,000 units
that is a huge amount of money for early
game mid game I don't know about late
games and I'm not there yet but that's a
lot of money and that's a pretty cool
reward for exploring coming in number
four you have traveling above a planet
to get somewhere so say you're on a
planet you're trying to go somewhere and
it says it's two hours away it's on the
same planet so you move pretty slow and
you're in your ship on the bottom of the
planet maybe like 135 UMAX so what
you're going to want to do is fly up out
of the atmosphere so you get into space
and then you're going to be able to use
your better boost you're going to be
able to pull strive jump to the location
where you want to be I will suggest that
you pull up a little bit since it does
have an auto aim feature to get you to
the location however it brings you in a
little bit too early
I suggest flying over it till you're
directly above it but still in space and
then go directly down that'll be the
fastest way to get to any location and
finally coming in at number five upgrade
to get better upgrades say you want your
multi-tool or your ship you just want a
more more slots so you start out with
sixteen slots you want 24 slots you came
across a bunch of animals you uploaded
all them you got like 7 million bucks
you want to buy great [ __ ] but you're
not seeing any ships with 24 slots this
is because your ship only has 16 slots I
don't know the exact numbers maybe you
do see 24 but the principle applies if
you don't upgrade from 16 to say 20 then
you won't be able to go to 20 to 24 same
thing with a multi-tool you have to
upgrade it to get the chance to buy
better ones right now I have a ship with
20 something slots and my option to
upgrade are in like around third
when I had a 16 ship slot I never saw
any of them and with this 20 something
ship slot I never really see 20 ones or
22s like the stuff that I saw when I was
in 16 so that's going to be it those are
my five tips if you want more of these
tips tell me in the comments that you
liked the video or like the video I
don't know show me that this video is
good and then I'll make more of them I
will be posting more no man's guy
content so if you want that be sure to
check around my channel maybe we'll do
some lower lowers pretty weird the deck
seemed a little a little loopy but yeah
thanks for watching and peace out